so what's coming up is this thing called
the transit of Venus and the reason why
it's a bit of an event is because
they're kind of they're not that
frequent although people may remember
there was one back in 2004 so you might
think why actually they are fairly
regular but it turns up they're only two
and then there's a gap for almost 100
years and then another two so they can't
you basically get them in pairs every
hundred years and so if you miss this
one you can have a pretty long wait for
the next one
so a transit is just where one object
passes in front of another and in this
particular case the transit of Venus is
just Venus passing between us and the
Sun and of course roughly speaking you
know that happens fairly regularly
because of course the various planets
all orbiting around the Sun and they
sort of you know they overtake from one
another so once in a while
planets will kind of lie more or less
between us and the Sun but because
things sort of wobble a little bit up
and down as well most of the time they
actually missed the disk of the Sun and
so the rarity of this event is it just
happens to be right across the face of
the Sun there's not like an eclipse of
the Sun where you know the moon happens
to have exactly the same angular sizes
the Sun pretty much so almost exactly
blotted out cause Venus is much much
smaller so all that will happen is a
tiny little black dot will trail across
the face of the Sun this is one of those
cases where you have to put in all the
usual take great care warning
instructions about this do not look
directly at the Sun with the unaided eye
do not whatever hams look through the
Sun at the Sun through a telescope the
only right way of doing this is with the
right equipment which in this case means
using a pair of those glasses which are
actually designed for looking at the Sun
and even then be careful because you've
got to check to make sure for example if
this if you've got one of those pairs of
Eclipse glasses and it's got a tiny
little scratch in it that tiny little
scratch the sunlight streaming straight
through there could do serious damage to
your eyes so make sure that these in
date they haven't expired and they
actually hasn't got any damage to it
before you look at the Sun but if you do
having put all those caveats in if you
have a pair of those those sort of mylar
glasses at a design for looking directly
the sign you can actually with the naked
eye see the little black dot just about
of Venus traveling across the face of
the Sun sort of cuts are rather uneven
slice off one edge of the Sun it doesn't
sometimes again we're exactly where it
passes through the Sun just depends on
on these act relative locations of the
Earth and Venus so this boat I mean I
guess there's both historical science
and current science right the historical
science is that this was actually how we
figured out how big the universe was
bizarrely so basically you could figure
out how far away things were relative to
the distance between the Earth and the
Sun right so there's this technique
called parallax that allows us to figure
out from the little wobbles of stars as
you view them as the earth goes around
the Sun how far that star is way but
that only works if you know exactly how
far the earth is from the Sun
and so the transit of Venus actually
gives a method for figuring out exactly
how far the earth is away from the Sun
at least in principle and the way this
works is again actually down to parallax
that if you observe the transit of Venus
at some point on the earth and you time
exactly when Venus disappears you know
when Venus starts crossing in front of
the Sun and when it leaves and then you
go to a different place on the earth or
actually since you only get the one shot
to do this somebody else has already
gone to a different place at a different
latitude and does exactly the same
measurement because they're viewing this
event from slightly different directions
one higher up on the earth the other low
down on the earth they'll actually see
the timings of these events slightly
differently and just from that
difference in timing that actually
allows you within with a little bit of
trigonometry to figure out how far the
Sun is away in terms of how far your two
observers were apart and because you can
measure distances on the earth that then
allows you at least in principle a way
of figuring out the distance of the Sun
and hence the scale of the entire
universe so historically that's why it
was sort of important now nowadays if
you want to figure out the scale of the
solar system there are much easier ways
of doing it you can for example just
fire a radar a pulse of radar at a
planet and wait for it to bounce back
and then the time it takes to travel
there and back tells you exactly how far
away the planet is so nowadays there
were kind of easier ways and much more
accurate ways of doing it but in the
sort of the 19th century when these
measurements will first be made
accurately this was the most accurate
way of figuring out the scale of the
solar system and hence then when you use
that to calibrate other measurements the
scale of the whole universe the trick
was to spread your your observers out as
far as you could so Captain Cook made
observations of this in Tahiti people
went to the southern seas there's lots
and lots of stories of there was some
poor guy French guy who actually went to
the southern seas to observe the transit
of Venus the first one was crack clouded
out entirely here Ament knew that there
would be another one in eighth year so
he then hung around there for eight
years
second one he actually made some
observations but he made them from a
ship and the ship's deck was heaving
around so much he didn't have to get any
good data so then he finally made his
way back to France and found that he'd
been declared dead in his absence and so
because of kids of scary stories that go
along with observing this it's a it has
to be a quite an accurate measurement
you make and actually it turned out to
be not as easy to do as had been assumed
because there's a strange effect called
the black drop effect which as
as Venus first so basically remember the
thing you need to do is measure very
accurately the time when the transit
begins when Venus first starts to travel
across in front of the Sun and this
weird thing the black drop effect means
that as Venus approaches the Sun it's
little disk if you're viewing it through
a telescope appears to get kind of
extended into a little droplet shape
almost a pear shape and so actually
measuring the price precise moment where
it first starts to disappear in front of
the Sun is actually a very hard thing to
do because it's no longer a nice perfect
circular object anymore and picking the
exact moment when it starts to travel in
front of the Sun turns out not to be
something you can measure particularly
precisely kind of intrinsically this is
about the hardest time you could
possibly try to observe Venus when this
up against the the glaring brightness of
the Sun you're much better observing
Venus kind of at night when it's throw
well away from the Sun but of course
what you're actually observing there
that transit is something that's being
used now to discover planets going
around other stars
so these transiting effects we're
actually seeing the little dips in light
that occur when other planets travel in
front of stars stars other than the Sun
and so in principle this is kind of a
useful calibration point because we
already know a lot about Venus to say
well can we make the same kind of
observation during the transit of Venus
that we will make of another planet
going around another star using the
telescope you know elsewhere now of
course it's not quite the same thing
because the Sun is blazing Lieb right
and actually the kind of instrumentation
you would use to detect a transit in
front of another star is completely
different but nonetheless there's things
that we can learn and there's been this
rather clever idea that someone's come
up with of rather than observing the Sun
directly and seeing one of these
transits occurring they're actually
going to point the Hubble Space
Telescope at the moon and look at the
reflected sunlight because of course to
the light you see from the moon is just
reflected sunlight but of course much
fainter so you can point the Hubble
Space Telescope at the moon without
doing your reparable damage to it that
you would if you pointed it at the Sun
and they're going to try to observe the
transit of Venus by pointing the
telescope at the moon and spotting the
little changes in the light from the
moon as Venus transits across in front
of the Sun this is an incredibly rare
astronomical event and you're an
astronomer a you're not going to get
another chance are you going to go are
you going to look at it it's a bit early
in the morning for me it's actually so
from the UK it's only visible it's the
event starts before sunrise and so
as the Sun rises in the UK the transit
will already be fairly well advanced and
it's about an hour left of the transit
and so that's about between about 4:30
and 5:30 in the morning which is bit
early for me
there's not be another one for a hundred
years it's a little black dot travelling
across the front of the Sun